we're getting some breaking news here
well yes it's it seems that the left is
still really mad is it what was that yes
no really really really mad more
specifically the left is furious about
judge fill-in-the-blank we're receiving
reports right now from NBC ABC CBS NY t
CNN the judge fill-in-the-blank is the
most dangerous and egregious Supreme
Court nominee in all of US history and
they are certain that he or she will
ensure the destruction of the republic
we will analyze the SCOTUS pick the
fallout and how republicans should react
then what the nomination means for the
midterms and Democrats central problem
I'm here to help as the leading expert
on the Democrat Party with writing the
most important political tome on the
Democrat Party I will explain do you
Democrats your problem all that more I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
so many thoughts on this nomination what
the nomination means for the court what
it means for the White House and also
just with the reaction because that's
that's really the best part of all of
this that's why we're all here isn't it
before we get to that got to make a
little money honey and I might make you
a little bit of money with a Lending
Club Lending Club is a great opportunity
for you
for decades credit cards have been
telling you to buy it now pay for it
later with interest and not just a
little bit of interest a lot of interest
despite your best intentions that
interest can get out of control very
fast with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt you can pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment don't do it it's so many people
are they're smart about a lot of things
but they're stupid about money
don't be stupid about money don't keep
paying really high interest a credit
card rates if you don't have to since
2007 Lending Club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with an affordable fixed-rate personal
loan no trips to the bank no high
interest credit cards you go to Lending
Club calm you tell them about yourself
and how much you want to borrow you pick
the terms that are right for you if
you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days this
is very important for Millennials
because we don't want to go anywhere you
know just wanna is assess it you just
kind of sit and then the money shows up
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion billion with ABI in loans
issued go to Lending Club comm slash
Knowles ko wles
check your rate in minutes borrow up to
$40,000 that is lemon club.com / Knowles
I should do that because Shapiro doesn't
pay me now maybe I could pay my rent
that way as if I go to Lending Club com
/ Knolls KO wles all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender
President Trump you know say what you
will about him that guy is so good for
civics for the civics education of the
United States and think about the
reality show nests of this nomination
how many first of all how many Supreme
Court potential nominees
you know PETA names that had been
floated possible judges that could go up
to the Supreme Court how many in history
did you ever know about none
maybe the nominee maybe and maybe like
one name maybe one other name not the
case with President Trump because
President Trump is the master of reality
television so for days now we've just
been on the edge of our seats Oh is he
gonna pick Amy I'd like Amy she's really
good-looking and she has seven kids and
she's super Catholic and I really wish
it were Amy damn it
we'll talk about that in a second or you
know is it going to be ray Catholic or
is it going to be a Cavanaugh Brett
Kavanaugh or is it gonna be Hardiman is
it going to be Pryor who's it gonna
write and we're all tuned into this this
is actually a good thing for American
civics because now that Donald Trump in
large part has made politics replace
entertainment we're paying attention to
it and we actually learn a few things
even you know the the Joe Schmo on the
street is picking up a few things
because it's dominating all of our media
so that I think is a good aspect of it
it's like edu tainment that's what they
say about Bill Nye except Bill Nye is
terrible you know Donald Trump is like
the good Bill Nye he wears loud clothing
you know he's I've been on television
since we were all kids and but he's like
the good version he does good things and
Bill and I just spout some nonsense so
let's get into it I've already shown my
hand a little bit with the Amy Barrett
with some especially cultural
conservatives we're really hoping for a
me koni Barrett who's a federal judge
who was nominated last year and
confirmed under President Trump and I
will say a little bit of this is just
the reality TV nosov it because before
three months ago what did you know about
any of these judges nothing nothing of
course not and what do you know now
probably not very much that you've read
a little bit I mean it's it has kind of
seeped in a little bit osmosis maybe
you've read some decisions or you've
read about some decisions so the the
cultural right was a little upset that
they whipped on Amy Kony Barrett she was
a clerk for Scalia she's written about
originalism pretty explicitly judge
Kavanagh who was ultimately nominated
they thought oh you know he's got ties
to the Bush family oh he talks a little
bit about precedent
I don't know about this but it's worth
pointing out intense hardline
rock-ribbed cultural organizations on
the right have come out in favor pretty
vocally of Brett Kavanaugh it's not like
Kavanagh is Justice Kennedy or Souter or
something like that that that's
ridiculous a National Right to Life says
that he has a good record as an
originalist the susan b anthony lists
pro-life list says that he's an
outstanding choice their quote tony
perkins from the Family Research Council
said quote judge Cavanaugh has a long
and praised where the history of judging
is originalist we look forward to having
a justice with his philosophical
approach on the court that's pretty good
you know I'm not saying this is the
perfect nominee ever but that's pretty
good we really don't have a lot to
complain about and remember we thought
it was gonna be Hillary so now it would
just be awful and our Constitution would
be ripped to shreds and then when Trump
got it there were a number of us myself
included who thought well he might be
like a Democrat he's been a democratic
points of his life he said very
left-wing things at various points he
might uh maybe the best we could hope
for is Kennedy and that's not true we're
getting much more originalist much much
more textualist more conservative
lowercase C justices including Brett
Kavanaugh that's pretty good you can't
really complain about that I also don't
want to become one of these like never
Trump people even for two seconds and
that is what the hill is it ran this
headline today hashtag never Trump errs
dominate media despite Trump party
loyalty at historic high and you might
have noticed that if you have tuned in
at all to the mainstream media which I
have not but they they get all these
guys on the on television like Bill
Kristol Steve Schmidt former GOP you
know who left Jennifer Rubin I don't
know that she was ever actually a
Republican but she plays one on TV Anna
Navarro and they just go there on TV all
the time except what's so strange about
that is that David Brooks Brett Stephen
I mean it goes on and on and I'm David
from what's so strange about that is
according to Gallup right now President
Trump has record high approval within
his own party eighty seven percent the
the polls show anywhere from 83 to 90
percent approval within his own party
this beats everybody this beats Ronald
Reagan there's one minor exception after
9/11 President Bush had us
comparable or higher approval rating
within his own party but that waned
shortly after 9/11 right now approval
among Republicans of Donald Trump is
higher than approval of Ronald Reagan at
his 500 day mark in office that is
pretty good the one caveat to cal say my
worries about Cavanaugh and then we'll
get into just celebrating it because the
leftist years are too much and will
drown if we don't celebrate and start
guzzling them quickly
the thing with Kavanagh is he better
have some some hard ribs he better
he really better show up because this is
this was a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity you've got a Republican
Senate you've got the swing vote the
major swing vote resigning and you've
got this conservative Republican
president in office you've got the
simple majority to confirm the Supreme
Court justice so we were like I you know
I kind of wanted a Atilla the Hun I was
campaigning for a justice hon or a
justice Kahn Ganga justice Genghis Khan
I thought he might be good to you really
want somebody who's hardcore like a Mike
Lee or apparently like a Justice Amy
Barrett judge Amy Barrett because you
you want to make sure that we can undo
some of the havoc that the left is
wrought on American the American legal
system in particular Roe vs. Wade in
particular but many other cases that
emanate from that and I think a lot of
cultural conservatives are a little
nervous because the the anti row v Wade
bona fides of Brett Kavanaugh or
slightly in question I don't want to
overstate this there are just certain
things that make us feel a little uneasy
we know that Justice Roberts gave us a
very an absurd opinion in Obamacare we
just we've been burned before we've been
burned by Roberts a little bit certainly
by Kennedy definitely by Souter oh very
much by Souter so we just don't want to
get burned again this is a once in a
lifetime opportunity I hope it works out
because if it doesn't work out the the
cultural right it's just never gonna
forgive the the the establishment right
and it is gonna create real fissures in
this party and it's gonna make the
nominating process even harder than it
was before so let's hope it works out
my last worry is about
judge Cavan I'll show you a little bit
just in the clip of his remarks last
night and then we'll get down to
celebrating here's Future Justice Rekha
Vanna the judge must interpret statutes
as written and a judge must interpret
the Constitution as written informed by
history and tradition and precedent my
law clerks come from diverse backgrounds
and points of yield
I am proud that a majority of my law
clerks have been women okay those were
two remarks that stuck out to me doesn't
seem like a huge deal that one Michael
you don't like women I love women when
look I was I was kind of hoping a woman
would be nominated to the court this
time I just found those remarks a little
worrying because he said the text has to
be interpreted by you know what the text
plainly means would have meant at the
time of ratification by tradition and
precedent and what we were assuming is
this was just a line he threw away for
the Democrats during the nominating
process so so they can point to it and
say no he accepts precedent he accepts
Tory decisis Justice Scalia himself no
less a man than the great great Justice
Scalia said that he was a faint-hearted
originalist because there is a role for
story decisis there is a role for
precedent in jurisprudence I just gone
we just get a little worried you just
think mmm what's that what does that
mean I don't know what that means and
then with the women remark he said I'm
proud that most of my clerks have been
women I just sort of thought like why
why are you proud of that I don't why
why do you care one way or the other if
the whole idea is that the the clerks
and the justices are supposed to
interpret the texts as they mean what
does their sexes have anything to do
with it it's just now look III know why
he did it he's kind of throwing out
these lines to make him more palatable
to Democrats I just think are we gonna
play that game is that what we it sounds
a little squishy just like I'm Pratt
it's like the binders full of women I'm
so proud that I that most of my
employees are women why who cares
it's fine if most of your employees or
women's find if most of your employees
are men what I don't care doesn't matter
it just those were the two things give
me a little I don't know about that now
we'll get to all the good stuff before
we do that we got to make a little more
money we have to this is look this is a
capitalist show this is a capitalist
country
we're conservatives here
you know thrive market and what is more
conservative than organic groceries
thrive market.com slash michael mi CH AE
l i really want to thank our sponsors at
thrive market because i love their
products i use it all the time you get
great savings on all of their products
you need to live a healthy life i am
actually really serious about this i
think there's this this idea this
caricature of some conservatives it's
like you know just eating sludge out of
the street which i don't need like good
food i don't but what are you talking
about think of like Winston Churchill or
something you know I think I think he
probably ate Ronald Reagan they think
you know they treated themselves well
you should to thrive market is a
revolutionary online marketplace on a
mission to make healthy living easy and
affordable for everyone you can shop for
thousands of the best selling non-gmo
foods and natural products always at
twenty five to fifty percent below
traditional retail prices check out the
thrive market brand products there they
are the highest quality ingredients at
even more affordable prices than the
current premium products carried on the
site I use a ton of their products all
the time I use their pignoli I use their
olive oil it's all superb quality you
won't get better quality and a really
good price if they offer a curated
catalog which means maybe you find three
or four choices
for whatever you want to buy because
they have picked out the best makes it a
lot easier I go to the grocery store up
on a rare occasion and I just am
overwhelmed that break out in hives
don't do that make your life easy more
than 70 percent with a thrive market
catalog cannot be found on Amazon it's
the largest retailer in the country that
sells exclusively non-gmo groceries it's
really really good users right now don't
say never did nothing for you we'll get
sixty dollars of free organic groceries
plus free shipping and a 30-day free
trial only my listeners though users
will get $20 off their first three
orders of $49 or more plus free shipping
but you're gonna spend more than $49
anyway they have such good products do
the math you spend forty nine bucks
thrive automatically gives you back 20
bucks so your total purchase becomes
thirty bucks you get this deal three
times in a row I'm no math major but
that is a good deal go to thrive market
I'm slash Michael get your instant 60
bucks off groceries thrive market calm
slash michael mi CH AE L alright let's
get to the good stuff
can we I'm done fretting I just wanted
to you know just wanted to get that off
my chest if it were if today you know we
had
like some you know Genghis Khan justice
Khan we're about to take control the
court and just obliterate roe v wade and
just the crash the administrative state
overturn Chevron deference I'd be
dancing on my desk but this is pretty
good too this isn't so bad one thing I
know that we have to do now that I've
gotten that off my chest is
conservatives and Republicans have to
unify behind Brett Kavanaugh we need to
unify behind this pic for a number of
reasons one he's a good pic he's a good
pic the main objection to him
from some quarters that he was a bushy
he worked for George Bush that's
ridiculous if you're a young legal star
in the last quarter century you're gonna
work for a bush that's just how we're
you know the bushes have been the
previous two Republican presidents
that's who you're gonna work for he he's
a good pic he's got a long record too
this was kind of the argument which I
felt about judge Barrett is she seems
great you know she seems so rock-ribbed
work for Scalia but she's only been a
judge for a year so there's not a lot of
record there and I actually did have
this thought I thought you know if judge
Barrett gets it and she turns out to not
be really rock-ribbed or originalist
down the road I'll feel kind of bad
because we're just we were making a
little bit of a bet here you know it was
only only one year that she's been a
judge this guy's been a judge for a
dozen years that's pretty good also the
president should have some leeway on
here this president has been good so far
he's been really good for conservatives
he's been the most conservative
president in in most ways that I've
certainly in my lifetime and that I
could even imagine really so that's
pretty good and the final reason why we
need to unify because you know the left
is gonna rip him apart they're already
trying to rip apart Judge
fill-in-the-blank the main reason we
have to unify and support judge Kavanagh
these tears are just so delicious
there's just so good again do you really
want to deprive yourself of these
because I I don't think I could do it
the left is generically outraged they're
not particularly outraged because they
don't know anything about this guy and
they were already outraged before the
pick came out but they're generically
outraged and that makes today so so
yummy mmm very good they outside there
was this major protest outside of the
Supreme Court
and I kid you not there were journalists
who caught photos of the people they
just showed up with fill in the blank
protest signs they say we need to stop
blank judge blank stop blanks nomination
blank is a racist blank as a second
whatever blank is gonna destroy women or
something it's the guy so you you are so
transparent in your just partisan
hackery there's nothing if you're not
even like you didn't even go into a
little corner and fill it no you just
showed up with a blank fill in the blank
sign and then the other great one if you
have if you sign up on political
websites and you have an email inbox and
I'm sure you saw this yesterday a bunch
of these left-wing organizations sent
out their generic fill in the blank
email and they forgot to fill in the
blank
so they this is the women's March
statement on Trump's extremist SCOTUS
nominee that was the headline of this
press release quote
a response to Donald Trump's nomination
of xx to the Supreme Court of the United
States the women's March released the
following statement all right it's not
like Xmas you know Christmas like it
stands in I don't think that works for
Brett Kavanaugh I think it's just this
big road if I wrote it a week ago
they say this is terrible it really
takes the wind out of their sails really
make their argument a little incredible
democracy for America another one these
left-wing groups sends out this message
SCOTUS DFA will fight Cavanaugh says she
represents a generational assault on
justice freedom and core democratic
values did you catch that did you catch
what happened there they thought it was
gonna be Barrett so they wrote they just
assumed they'd put the pronoun she' I
can't believe by the way democracy for
America they didn't even ask judge
Cavanaugh his preferred pronoun did they
assume his gender they have to ask you
have to ask your preferred pronoun it's
totally weak hackery but it wasn't just
them you know he was everybody was all
of these activists at the Supreme Court
Shannon Breen for Fox was out there she
was gonna do a show a live show at the
Supreme Court they had to shut it down
because she felt unsafe she said I've
never really felt unsafe reporting on
the ground this is insane way worse than
the
or such nomination which is funny
because it seems like Gorsuch is a more
rock-ribbed nominee I'm not entirely
sure that's fair it's really hard to
rank judges on scales of conservatism or
originalism because there are just so
many issues that come before them but
yeah they apparently the protests
against this guy Cavanaugh were much
much worse than against Gorsuch why is
that it's just all fake astroturfed
election year nonsense so let's get to
what really matters because the democrat
activists waited and that's fine the
democrat pacs wait in that's fine but
the real leaders of that party
the real spokesman are the celebrities
they're my neighbors here in sunny
hollywood and with the the things they
tweeted were both they were disingenuous
they were fill in the blank and they
were also just like very stupid this is
always the case in hollywood that's why
my tumblr is especially full this
morning i know some of you in the center
of the country in on the east coast you
don't get to enjoy quite as many salty
tears as i do
joss whedon the director it tweets out
even considering this nomination will
cement the first american dictatorship
Cavan no get it his name's Cavanaugh
Kevin no so it will cement the first
American dictatorship I don't think
there's ever been an American dictator
if there had would it be Donald Trump
the guy who's lowered taxes increased
religious liberty decreased regulation
would it be that guy or the one who
remained president for the entire rest
of his life four terms interned
japanese-americans just put a bunch of
americans into prison camps tried to
stack the court overturn the
constitutional order create blatantly
anti constitutional government programs
which one would it be would it be that
guy the great democrat President
Franklin Roosevelt where would it be
Donald Trump who despite all of the
press releases and all of the the
Democrat hullabaloo to the to the
contrary is not authoritarian at all has
not shown any authoritarian tendencies
whatsoever a great question just weed
you know if you know maybe his
historical knowledge only goes back to
like 98 yeah
yeah but you got to go back a little
further man so ron perlman another one
he was an L boy hello boy ron perlman
tweets out okay ladies and gentlemen who
care for and respectful ladies it is
official the move back to medieval
values Sharia law even where old bitter
men get to tell women what is best for
their bodies lives and well-being is as
done a deal as this is unless we say no
no medieval values I actually love
medieval values I don't know that he
totally understands medieval values
scholasticism all that great height for
the Catholic Church but I I do love this
I've noticed that the left does this
sometimes when they're attack they tell
us is LOM is the religion of peace Islam
is wonderful they call people who
question some aspects of Islamic
doctrine or history they call us
Islamophobic they say Islam is wonderful
religion of peace and then the minute
they want to insult Christianity they
compare it to Islam Christianity is so
bad it's like Sharia law yes you were
just defending Sharia law where you just
say no diya that was yet but yesterday
Sharia law was good but now it's bad
because so I do it is a really fun
little place they put themselves in
because the best way to attack
Christianity is to admit that Islam
might not be a perfect religion of peace
so great job thanks for that Hellboy
next one up from Rob Reiner from
meathead himself meathead tweets at its
official Trump who is under
investigation for obstruction of justice
and conspiring with an enemy to destroy
democracy by the way random
capitalization thread all of that they
always knock Trump for randomly
capitalizing things he does the exact
same thing he goes on has selected the
judges who could rule on whether he can
be forced to testify be indicted or
pardoned himself autocracy here we come
vote so that isn't true
the indictment thing we'll get to that
actually Jon Cryer puts this in stark
light so it was just ranted I mean that
was basically what Rob Reiner said it's
brotherbrother number because it what he
was saying just reference things that
aren't true and that is the question
that they seem to have settled on even
though it was answered hundreds of years
ago can a president sitting president be
indicted jon cryer who is on that
CBS show the one with Charlie Sheen's
sidekick Jon Cryer tweets out quote the
first question every Democratic senator
should ask Kavanagh will you recuse
yourself from any case involving whether
the president can be subject to criminal
investigation required to testify or
indicted why would he recuse himself
what is he why would that happen
what Cryer I think is suggesting is
because judge Cavanaugh has has an
opinion on that has written about that
issue that he should recuse himself just
follow the logic of that for a second if
judges who have had written opinions
about public matters recuse themselves
when those matters came up to higher
courts there wouldn't be any judges
anymore because that's their job so they
do they write opinions on public matters
they could be then having an opinion on
a public matter is not grounds for
recusing yourself you recuse yourself of
there's some conflict of interest or
something you know if you if if judge
Kavanagh were Donald Trump's son perhaps
he should recuse himself or but because
he had an opinion about it that would
that's the premise of the judiciary but
no one's ever blamed Network sitcom
actors for for being too too precise in
their historical knowledge the other
question here is is that Rob Reiner
brings up Jon Cryer brings up all these
guys are bringing up can the president
be indicted the Democrats are focusing
in on this line of attack they're gonna
say Cavanaugh is he's really there to
help Trump not be indicted for but
whatever like the president can't be
indicted the sitting president of the
United States can't be indicted this is
not a debated legal question this is not
a really difficult one to figure out if
you have Google you'll figure it out
Alexander Hamilton's settled the
question pretty clearly in Federalist 69
he wrote quote the President of the
United States would be liable to be
impeached tried and upon conviction of
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors removed from office and
would afterwards be liable to
prosecution and punishment in the
ordinary course of law so Donald Trump
could be indicted for something but
president Trump could not in order to
indict the president what you have to
first do is impeach him
I am find him guilty to convict him
remove him from office and then you can
deal with indicted him or whatever you
want to do it that is there I don't I I
guess they've never read the Federalist
that of course Lee obviously Democrats
have never read the Federalist Papers if
they had they'd be Republicans but they
they don't understand that this is a
this is a simple matter the question of
of these celebrities is I look
celebrities are always dummies they
always say stupid things the mainstream
media are really to blame here because
they should know better they are so
focused on this line of attack this
secret backroom deal and it's a
machination and Trump colluded with the
Federalist Society and whatever they you
know they probably think the Federalist
Society is like an arm of the KGB in
Moscow or something Liane Caldwell at
MSNBC reported that there was a secret
backroom deal for months of negotiations
that Justice Kennedy would name his
successor and only then would he retire
and this and none of that makes any
sense but what was was really
interesting about that report from NBC
is that it's based on nothing they even
NBC had to sort of walk it back but the
way they do it of course is they say
some outrageous ridiculous stupid thing
without any sourcing and then everyone
tweets it and that spreads everywhere
and it's out in the ether and then
little later on they say oh but maybe we
weren't right but nobody tweets that one
nobody tweets the correction nobody
tweets the retraction so what Lee Ann
Caldwell at NBC reported is there were
these assurances these backroom deals
was all this haggling with Justice
Kennedy which of course makes no sense
if you look at the incentives for any of
that to happen but she based that on one
source that wasn't didn't hear firsthand
any of that happening he heard it as a
secondhand rumor from someone else who
also isn't named so they're sore is not
corroborated by anybody is just like
gossip in the children's cafeteria
now that's NBC that's what they've
reduced themselves to but but that's
they're just hacks at this point right
they're not actually doing investigative
journalism they're just they've just
become
haxe I wish they knew something here
because it would make it sort of more
interesting to grab hold of and argue
with them but it is really entertaining
that they don't know anything at this
point I actually think president Trump
have nominated Merrick garland and they
would find a way to attack him well it
was a backroom deal with garland
Garland's now a Republican or something
it doesn't make any sense all all of the
lefties who know nothing are extremely
mad there is one lefty whom I actually
know who knows something because he's a
leading expert on constitutional law and
that is a Yale professor Akhil amar and
he wrote a big piece in the New York
Times today defending judge Kavanagh and
professor amar is a lefty there is no
doubt about it he was a professor while
I was in college he was always very nice
whenever I would speak to him a very
cordial i sat in on a number of his
lectures a very very sharp guy but
decidedly a left winger and you know I
think even when he was in college he was
the head of the liberal party of the
debating society he wrote this piece a
vocal defense of Judge Cavanaugh and
it's really interesting because I think
we the Conservatives should hone in on
that and use that to separate the left
each packs from vaguely serious lefties
he writes in the New York Times the
nomination of Judge Brett Kavanaugh to
be the next Supreme Court justice as
president Trump's finest hour his
classiest move I know I'm as worried as
you are at this point reading this from
from former lefty professor but
nevertheless he's a sharp guy listen to
his logic he says last week the
president promised to select someone
with impeccable credentials great
intellect unbiased judgment and deep
reverence for the laws and constitution
of the United States in picking judge
Cavanaugh he's done just that
in 2016 I strongly supported Hillary
Clinton for president as well as
President Obama's nominee for the
Supreme Court judge Merrick garland but
today with the exception of the current
justices in judge garland it's hard to
name anyone with judicial credentials as
strong as those of judge Cavanaugh he
goes on Democrats could try to sour the
hearings by attacking judge Cavanaugh
and looking to complicate the
proceedings whenever possible this would
be a mistake judge Kavanaugh again is a
superb nominee really strong words from
a Adel
eating light of a leading left-wing
legal scholar and a really prominent
figure there was some talk of him
possibly being nominated to the court by
President Obama this is a big guy and a
big deal and he's right he's really
right if if there is a political
strategy here which of course there is
to the nomination of Cavanaugh it's that
it will make Democrats look foolish you
know the the the political idea behind
nominating justice Barrett is it would
become this religious fight you'd have
Democrats ripping apart religion on
national television and it wouldn't play
well in Peoria and they lose the
midterms this one is good too though
because he's this basically
unimpeachable candidate he's not the the
furthest most hardcore originalist or
conservative on the court among the
names that were floated and so we'll
just make them look foolish when he goes
up there during the confirmation process
a Kavanagh also is by all accounts so
smart and will sail through because I
think his IQ is about 17 standard
deviations higher than making rational
IQ on average but we should we should
take a look on that because a professor
I'm more he concludes this piece he says
what we should we the Democrats should
push for a compromise vote yes Senate
Democrats should vote YES on Kavanagh or
clearly state to better nominees who
even possibly could have been nominated
by this administration by a Republican
administration though yes or state to
better people and of course no Senate
Democrat could do that they probably
couldn't name three federal judges
period and in exchange for that Kavanagh
would answer all of the questions fairly
in that case the reasoning here is that
judge Kavanagh could be nominated by
your confirmed by 90 plus votes instead
of the 50 or 51 votes and he's going to
get to be confirmed that would be nice
it would be good in the United States to
have some sense that not everything is
just some bitter partisan battle in some
hacked battle you know that there
actually is some consensus over what the
role of government is what the role of
the executive is how the Senate can play
a role in that to advise and consent
from these justices it would be smart
for Democrats to do that so you know
what that means they're not going to do
it they're certainly not going to do it
I think professor amar knows they're not
going to do it he's pleading with them
in the New York Times but it just isn't
going to happen because this is a bitter
bitter fight and it also will back some
Democrats into a corner in these red
states states that President Trump won
by a landslide it's really gonna put
them in a tough spot it's gonna either
rip them off their base or rip them off
of the broader electorate new polling
supports this this is the good news
drive to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube I do
oh let's mm I was just gonna we're gonna
get into like the central problem of the
Democrat Party and why this still spells
really good news for Republicans in
November but I'm sorry if you're on
Facebook or YouTube go to daily whiter
calm right now
why forget it you know you get the shows
you can ask questions in the mailbag
whatever we've got the conversation
coming up by the way next one with the
Supreme Lord of the multiverse Andrew
Clavin from just forget all of that
today
forget all of it forget getting the
bench Shapiro's wife is a doctor t-shirt
on amazon right now forget and forget
anything in the Daily wire orbit other
than this you're gonna need this to get
through the confirmation hearings you
won't survive
you're gonna get borked you're gonna get
like like stick a Bork in him you're
done you're gonna be dead if you don't
have your leftist use tumblr because you
will drown go to daily wire duck I'm
right now we'll be right back
so what does this mean for the midterms
it looks like we're gonna be able to get
judge Cavanaugh through the confirmation
process before the midterm elections
that would be a very good thing would
make it much easier to do that will the
GOP hold the Senate will the GOP lose
the Senate I don't know historically
speaking again you know the the party
that's in power the party that holds the
White House is at a great disadvantage
in Congress a new major batch of polls
from Axius shows that Republicans are
likely to hold the Senate 52 to 48 so
actually we would gain gained momentum
in the Senate don't I'm loath to report
that because I don't want anybody
getting comfortable this is gonna be a
tight election in histories against us
but we could hold that that would be
very good news because then we could
push another justice at some point
obviously no one no one wishes ill of
any of the left-wing justices but you
know if two father time retires them
where they choose to retire sometime
during the Trump administration we could
push a a conservative and an originalist
on a textual judge through the polling
looks good for Republicans but not great
there is a specific polling on this
issue the Tarrance group has a poll out
that shows the majority of voters in
battleground states want the nominee
confirmed they want president Trump's
nominee confirmed by fair majorities in
Florida it's 56 percent Indiana I think
it's also 56 percent a Missouri 57
percent North Dakota 68 percent West
Virginia 59 percent they want this to go
through now what does that mean for guys
like joe Manchin or Claire McCaskill
people who are Democrats nominal
Democrats at least in these battleground
states though are they going to have to
vote for the nominee it's gonna put them
in a real pickle and probably that's the
case also interesting finding on this
group of this poll from terrence group
is that the majority of people in these
battleground states want abortion to be
decided by the legislature not by an
activist court writing laws this is a
big deal because we've been talking
about roe v wade a lot this week this is
a huge deal this is a shift in public
opinion not just on the question of
abortion which has moved in the pro-life
direction since the road
decision now the country split
fifty-fifty and when you really drill
down I think it's probably more pro-life
oh but this is a big split on federalism
this is a big split on separation of
powers on the different roles of
government because Rovi weighted isn't
just about abortion it's about what the
court gets to do does the court get to
write laws does does the legislature
have a say do the people ever say to the
states have a say in the laws that
govern them or do the courts just 9 you
know black-robed kings and dictators do
they get to say what goes on these are
the small oligarchy well it seems the
public opinion is shifting in favor of
separation of powers of the the
legislature actually doing what it's
supposed to do that's a really great
move now with all of these numbers going
against them all of this this tide
turning against them the deluge of
leftist tears flowing down upon us what
are the Democrats doing what do you
think they're gonna do I think they're
maybe gonna moderate a little do you
think do you think maybe they're gonna
try to get on board come up with some
new know they're gonna nominate Hillary
they're gonna nominate Hillary Clinton
she's running again it's she's at least
running now who knows if she'll ever
officially declare that she's running
she might peter out eventually but she
is behaving as though she is running for
president she's going to major events
she went to an event for the American
Federation of Teachers gave speeches
with Bernie and Elizabeth Warren this
big you know 2020 contenders Democrat
contenders for president their combined
ages seven thousand or something 750,000
the Hillary also has this super PAC now
that that she's running onward together
this is being run by Brian Fallon her
former campaign press secretary and why
is she spending all this money why she
raising money why she's spending money
because she's behaving as though she's
running for president but what are the
other options the other options are
Pocahontas and Bernie Sanders crazy old
Bernie this goes back to a strategy from
Democrats in 2006 when Howard Dean took
over that party and he said I'm from the
Democrat wing of the Democrat Party and
we're gonna run left we're gonna move
far left and what the Democrats did is
they doubled down on their their most
radical base they doubled down on these
slot a sipping lefties who have disdain
for their fellow countrymen and it sort
of worked for them in the short term but
it's moved them
away from other key aspects of their
coalition specifically on base issues
and the question of do you believe in
God these are like very essential
bedrock questions of politics politics
is downstream of culture culture is
downstream of of the cult of what we
worship on that basis the vast majority
of white Democrats or practical atheists
they don't believe in a God that
resembles the God of the Bible
the vast majority and yet the vast
majority of Hispanic Democrats and black
Democrats do believe in God that this
creates a big issue on fundamental
questions first principles questions
like that the Hispanic and black voters
what the Democrats would call the
coalition of the ascendant this kind of
intersectional coalition of various
demographic groups who might not share a
theology but they should share some
combined grievance or something they
more closely resembled Republicans and
you're seeing a shift away from the
Democratic Party the great walk away
this was trending on Twitter the other
day this is great news for Republicans
really really stupid for Democrats and
that that central problem that they have
that they've had now for at least 12
years but probably many many more
decades than that is the Democrats have
no imagination that's their problem they
have no imagination 2020 they just get
clobbered by President Kofi fais you
know they get clobbered by this guy who
is a reality TV star they thought is
gonna be the easiest candidate to beat
ever and what do they do they say maybe
will nominate Hillary again or that
other or that lady who looks exactly
like Hillary but says that she's in the
indian or that guy who kind of looks
like hillary - you know but has that
voice from Seinfeld maybe or Curb Your
Enthusiasm maybe that's what we should
do these Pete these decrepit old people
they don't have any imagination they
don't have any new idea what is their
new idea what is the the big move that
Alexandria Cortes is pushing the the
Democrat nominee for Congress in Queens
that Bernie Sanders is pushing that Liz
Warren is pushing the Kirsten Gillibrand
is pushing they're pushing socialism is
there anything more old and decrepit and
unimaginative than socialism socialism
and as a modern form has been around
since the 1820s that's their new idea
are you kidding me that's pathetic that
is pathetic but they're a party of
decrepit old people and decrepit old
ideas and they're doubling down on its
really good you see it in the
the signs at the protest those blank
signs that shows you the Democrat Party
they have no imagination it's just blank
it's just fill in the blank we must
oppose the extremist racist sexist
violent misogynist judge blank this is
like a template they didn't even get
like I move a couple words around or
something we they say everywhere these
Republicans you're all racists and
sexist Cabot Phillips from campus reform
he went out before the nominee was
picked and he just asked these NYU
students on the street he said hey what
do you think of Trump's new nominee who
had not yet been picked and they so yeah
very racist very dangerous very sexist
just making it up just because that's
just they're like robots they're
automatic
that are just programmed to repeat these
tired old lines and it's it's part of
that ideology it's because when you're
in that very ideological mindset you
just kind of get broken down a little
bit you know you go on autopilot you
don't see things around you idiot logs
don't see the world they just see these
narrow narrow takes on the world they
don't they don't have they're not really
perceiving things in real time and it's
good news for us because the the trumpet
era is anti ideological isn't it I mean
he was not a checklist conservative
candidate he didn't check most of the
boxes but he's delivered some of the
best conservative public policy judicial
nominations were just in like the age of
cough FA this is really good by the way
I'm doing this tour with yaf it's coming
up this fall a young America's
Foundation we're gonna be doing all of
this a cofee on campus tour and we'll be
taking on a lot of issues I will define
what khofifah is people seem not to
understand what Kofi phase I'll give you
the real definition you'll finally learn
but you see it in the Trump era in the
age of cough FA that this thinking
outside the box to borrow a cliche this
this cracking old checklists and
cracking old ideologies actually allows
you to affect your political vision much
more easily and the Democrats are
falling into that trap
they have nothing new about them nothing
imaginative nothing afresh nothing alive
about them I hope that Republicans are
able to maintain this and one way we're
going to be able to do it is rallying
around this judge even if he's not our
favorite pick you know really it's only
because of the age of Kofi FA that we
even knew there
other pics available really even
thinking about them because of this
reality TV show because of this
right-wing exuberance and we got a rally
around if for no other reason one
because it's important to protect our
Liberty one another one because it's
important to win more elections and keep
the momentum going in this Liberty
movement the other one is just these
tears man you just need it you just if
you're if you're missing out on this you
are missing out on the single singular
political delight of our lifetimes don't
do it don't do it don't don't let you
know be talking to your grandkid in 50
years and say grandpa what were you
doing during the age of Kofi Fame were
you oh I was I was thirsty
I was parched I was parched what can I
say I didn't it didn't occur to me I'm
sorry now it was a different time we
didn't know don't do that don't say that
you want to be able to look your grin
grandkids square in the eye you say your
great granddaddy was guzzling leftist
tears I was 80 percent saline I turned
into a pillar of salt like Lot's wife
that's our Shh sorry so free today come
back tomorrow get your mail back
questions and there's a lot more to talk
about but I really wanted to go in a
little bit on what this judge means
today sip them up enjoy them we're gonna
have a we're gonna have a nice couple
couple salty cocktails later on today
and I will see you tomorrow I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you